I love everyone welcome back to the
games what stage here at e3 2016 joining
myself and Scott Butterworth on the
couch today is Jason who's a lead writer
on edge writer may have writer thank you
thank you GameSpot Thank You airhead
bytes for having me haha we didn't ask
him to say that no no I'm just I'm a big
fan I uh how did you not be how could I
know you eat delicious they fit in a
pocket they do and they match your shirt
I'll thank you yeah yeah plant this this
is official volition purple you have
your own like cat Bree cat Bree has a
purple yeah we have a purple they don't
bring up don't pick up the cat very
purple I can t very sensitive subject
I'm so sorry I'm good though I had the
purple war runs deep yeah I mean alright
let's talk a little ro no let's talk a
little
speaking of Saints Row wait mmm-hmm
thank you the end of saints were full
yeah hey the guys you know they've
defeated an alien invasion hmm boilers
said well I mean do you need to play
like Angry already but you know like
there was a big simulation thing that
was um don't want to miss a thing on a
rocket that was a that was a whole yes
oh where the hell do you go from that uh
well you go to get out of hell which
followed the events of sr4 yeah and then
you go to agents of mayhem which is a
brand new IP from Deep Silver volition
but it is part of the larger saints row
universe right so we we bring over
elements and fan favorite things into
into a om hang on is that Johnny Gat
confirmed oh that was a long time
airhead bites ha ha ha ha uh no we uh go
smooth out have a good improv yeah yeah
uh so guess what what elements dress I
wear what save these guys in breath ok
what elements from zero what what I mean
so given that it is the team that
created Saints Row right what kind of
gameplay simulator is can we expect
between the two games
well volusion's special sauce right as
we make third-person open-world action
games that are fun funny over-the-top
agents of mayhem brings that and along
with a cast of really colorful
characters and so it's a lot of
still out of humor like character based
humor a lot of ridiculous situations I
think in some ways we live in bigger and
crazier than the Sancho series ever did
you that's a bold claim because I mean
Saints Row got pretty big and pretty
crazy it did it did but we have some
amazing things in the works so what what
has so now we have sort of like I don't
know how you would necessarily describe
your characters but it seems like these
were secret agent types they are we call
super agents amoral super agents with
license to do whatever it takes to save
the world from the supervillains
organization known as Legion mayhem and
Legion as a global fight but agency
ma'am takes place in Seoul South Korea
which is a legion is try stablishing a
president's trying to grab all the
technology there but it's a center of
Technology in the a om universe and
mayhem is going to stop them but how are
they gonna do that that is a good
question with a lot of guns and but also
special abilities and what we call
mayhem abilities that are unique to
every agent and they allow you to do
some really crazy things control the
battlefield really really gonna throw
things throw a wrench in the works so
how does game kind of play out is it
like a multiplayer or is it keep playing
single-player open-world experience it
has you know has a main story but lots
and lots of stuff in the open-world
Legion is constantly dropping doomsday
devices all over the street messing up
people's day make them late for work so
we're seeing a lot of different
character circa you can customize your
own character are you playing as a cast
of characters you're playing as a cast
of characters we have 12 agents and
agents of mayhem you take three of them
out in the field as a squad you can swap
between them really quickly just press
the d-pad and you can change and that
allows you to create synergies between
the different abilities and the first
customization it's a lot of upgrades
every agent has unique upgrade paths you
can specialize their their special
ability you can give them past them
ability stuff like that and then there
is a we have some skin customization as
well so you mentioned you can change the
three the amount on the battlefield ones
can you give like orders to the AI or is
it just no you you switch to them so so
you have control over every agent so if
you want to set them up a fortune her
she has a drone named glory
and her mayhem ability launched his
glory out and then glory just sends all
this electricity out there and stuns the
bad guys and then you can immediately
switch to say hartack who has a shotgun
and gun run in and just lay waste to
them awesome
so you mentioned it's in Seoul is that
like how much of a big departure from
steel for does it for you guys gifted
like I used to not to create it from the
ground up yeah well you know steel port
and Stillwater were based on the iconic
American cities there was the ideas of
iconic American cities Seoul South Korea
is we take it to next step into the
future this game takes place after Lee
Jen launched a global simultaneous
attack against the world and Seoul is
rebuilding and they are the most
technologically advanced city in the AOM
universe and so building it the big
difference is it's very colorful the
entire game is very colorful colorful
paired you take a lot of inspiration
from comics and cartoons we bring that
over visually as well as in the style of
the characters so as you're running
around you're going to see a mix of you
know traditional of temples right next
to very futuristic high-rises and it all
has a flavor of Seoul South Korea that
we kind of we our interpretation in the
UM universe so it was 12 characters mmm
doesn't mean there's like 12 different
paths is eight different interactions
different we want people to have the
agents they adore and as lead writer a
big thing for me is I want someone who
absolutely loves the character to not
feel like oh I got this character later
so it I'm not having as much fun or I
don't get to see as much because you
know I got them however many hours after
I got another one I want I want them to
be like I love this character and and
when I play as this character I get just
as much quality content I get just as
much of experiences every other agent so
you don't get them all from the very
beginning you kind of unlock them as you
go that's correct right to build on what
Lucy was asking I think so if it does
the story or dialogue change depending
on who you bring into a mission with you
it does it changes who you are currently
acting as the dialogue changes who you
have in the squad that you're not
currently being that changes and then
there's banter there's a lot of banter
so you take people out and they have
relationships or you know some some
agents get along really well some don't
some have kind of you know some have
history that isn't always the best and
so you get to explore I call it an
office comedy because it's so character
Basin is all about people who have to
work together and you know I'm sure you
coworkers
I don't hate each other yeah I figured
yeah I mean before the segment it was
yeah I was really tense in this room
here accent it's really funny yes do it
oh I'm joking come on what I loved about
in the central games obviously in sintra
for the big like the mocking send-up of
like the Bioware romances either that's
hilarious
yeah is it gonna be some interoffice
love and relationships I think you can
expect that yes all right again you know
you mentioned like a Saints Row is known
for lovingly referencing elements of pop
culture right we're in on the joke with
with the the player agents of mayhem
continues that we bring over a lot of
pop culture of superheroes comics
cartoons and it we bring the gamer in
with us because we're all just we're all
in on this together and we treat us a
loving Langston so does it get a little
a little crass and inappropriate like
Saints Row I mean there's a few you know
memorable weapons and things like that
but you know yeah had a real life one of
those in the office yeah oh let's talk
about that Oh tell me what sorry well
yeah what I'm sorry uh yes you know
every agent has a different personality
some of them such as Rama a very stoic
very dry Gallow sense of humor and then
you have other agents who are quite
crass who you know aren't beyond
slapping their co-workers on the butt
like what's the kind of liberating to
have all these different characters to
write for as opposed to having just one
central bureau that you know was kind of
carrying the entire experience it really
was we have a global cast of characters
so we have all different you know
nations and belief systems and
viewpoints and so it's great to build a
new world and then explore it through 12
different characters who all come from
different backgrounds who all have
different ideas of what mayhem should be
and what
the real threat of Legion and how they
work together it's fantastic it's kind
of a writers dream to be able to tell a
story repeatedly through the eyes of
different different people what I want
to know is is Nolan North gonna make a
return uh-huh as Nolan not just just
agent Nolan North I would love that but
work yeah would work they're pretty
great with like a Nathan Drake skin
mm-hmm
maybe it's just get away with this DLC
right yeah open it later ain't no 'ln if
you're watching let's talk
of course he's watching everyone's
watching he's watching everything all
the time that's probably true it's like
Watchmen he says that's that huge wall
of screens he's just constant looking
everything yeah I mean to her Baker have
a you know like a bunker somewhere I
think than just I think that's my sector
yeah Rinne yeah get the button a
trapdoor opens that's good on the voice
actor pole yeah the voice actor 'mobile
drive to where they're needed there's a
voice actor cabal out there I'm sure of
it there has to be now it has to be um
so I mean what is it it's gonna be
current gen yes I mean Saints Row for
obviously came out Xbox 360 and then was
bought to xbox Xbox one and ps4 right
this is gonna be like the first title
you guys have built yeah we're building
a ground up for the current generation
it's coming out Xbox one ps4 and PC the
big three the big three has it been kind
of a challenge to move on to this new
hardware I mean he's given that this is
those teams from what I understand the
team's first game on the new console
generation that's right so I mean as a
writer I look at programming and I just
nod and say good job that's some number
so but I know that I look at the game
and I am impressed by the art style I'm
really impressed by how it runs
creatively what I really like about this
new generation of consoles last gen we
proved that we can do photorealistic we
proved that we could build worlds that
seem like you're inside of it really
excites me about the current generation
of consoles is people are exploring more
stylized worlds you know and so they're
having more fun with the art their
things are becoming you know more iconic
rather than realistic and in am a women
is the freedom to to build a really
colorful world so I like that a lot
that's what I really enjoy but then the
new gen consoles and agents of man let's
talk about your bad guy he's just [ __ ]
up on screen so what's his name dr.
Babylon dr. Babylon
how far is he away from like we had we
had zinyak insights before he he looks
more like traditional evil mastermind uh
he he is so legion is broken in
different subsets and in in soul
it's the Ministry of Pride and dr.
Babylon is the minister of pride he's
the top of the org chart but he brought
along with them
numerous lieutenants each of whom are
just as colorful as the agents and have
their own unique brand of insanity I
like to call dr. Babylon our mana logger
he is he is the Bond villain who will
just sit there and drone on and on about
how brilliant he is while you are
escaping the death trap yeah and then
all the other agents we have a steel toe
here at e3
he is a transhumanist who wants to a
transition entirely over to be machine
and who doesn't and there's a love story
there's a love story in there
return him in a machine really you're
naughty I love the fact that we brought
a romantic comedy to to e3 and it's
resonating so hard but yeah yes you know
games really do need more romantic
comedies they do we are free to do that
you know agents of mayhem
we're you know yes we're shooter yes you
roam around this open world but that
doesn't mean we can't do some really
crazy crazy things that just tell a love
story between you know two digital
beings so in terms of mission structure
and is it gonna be like in zero for it
was you could obviously had like the
main mission structure and then you had
like a bunch of side quests side mission
like insurance fraud and stuff is it
going to be the same this way it is we
have we have a main story that you go
through that'll take you through the big
arc in your fight against the Ministry
of pride but legion is constantly
dropping doomsday devices and and
they're there they're fighting to
maintain control of soul so you'll be a
saving in parts of the city you will be
reclaiming parts of the city it's going
to be it's gonna be fun you know there's
there's going to be lots to do in anyway
can you talk a little about what kind of
side quests you know like what will be
an example of something you can do
outside of the main story missions in in
the demo we drop a dark matter energy
pour into the street and so legions
advantage their title advantages our
ability to manipulate dark matter
so they drop this core and it just it
upsets gravity and it starts pulling in
people walking down the street cars even
bad guys and she's are sucking in that
part of soul and you have to go shut it
down and so if you don't then you know
bad things can happen
sounds bad yeah yeah gravity I've heard
it's important I don't really know I
have a little bit of experience with it
but not much
so is your bass gonna be in set in soul
and you just kind of pop out or is it
gonna be like a floating spaceship or
something like with what you guys come
up with before right right so in mayhem
HQ which which has its own cast of
characters including a lot of people who
are gonna interact with through the
missions where perséphone brimstone is
located who's the head of mayhem and
Friday her second-in-command it's a
central location that gives you access
to all sorts of encounters with Legion
oh so well Jason do we have a release
date for agents of Mason that's great
agent may have met it's Thursday yeah I
do I do
gamespot exclusive in 2017 2017 mmm
thank you so much for joining us oh I
have one final question for sure who we
went in a fight agents of shield uh-huh
mayhem you really you're gonna ask me
that's you look I've got I worked by
airhead bytes agents of mayhem is gonna
trash agents for [ __ ] you heard it here
first folks
70 70 none for more coverage from this
year's e3 of course make sure you stay
tuned to games.com